now the Home Secretary has gone under
pressure this week to freely women being
held y'alls would that's the detention
center for female asylum seekers a
demonstration outside the home office
had the support of MPs actors and
campaigners one job I
meltem asell who was detained at yonce
word when she was just 13 years old
Natasha Walter is the founder of women
for refugee movement in a very good
morning to Melton we only talk to you
first of all held at 13 just describe to
us some of the circumstances how did you
get to the UK and how did you end up in
y'all's would my mum and we when we came
into the UK we applied for asylum and we
had to wait for six years before any
decision was made and after well this
decision was that we were rejected so
then you have a right of appeal not on
that point no we had to be taken away in
a caged van by eight immigration
officers to y'all's would and then we
could appeal whilst we were locked up
and just tell us which country you came
from and how you got into the UK um we
came from Turkey and the the traveling
part I was very young I don't really
remember the traveling part but we came
from Turkey because of political reasons
to England and you know we I went to
school for six years I had friends and I
was learning the language I was doing
stuff and then one morning eight
immigration officers came and you know
dragged us out of the house people to be
interested to hear more of your stories
we get to the point you know tease that
out in a moment or two but first of all
what does this tell us then about how
the UK asylum system is working and tell
us about facilities and conditions in
yeah I mean one thing I do want to say
is that Mel I met Mount Hermon yes would
when she was just 13 years old
and we were campaigning together then to
end the detention of children and that
detention was that that campaign was
actually successful so children are no
longer being locked up in the ours would
and what's so interesting is that that
camp a were successful children are no
longer being locked up but there's been
no rise in absconded among families as a
result and we're saying to the
government come on there are better ways
of dealing with people's asylum claims
than locking them up in this arbitrary
way and I think it's very telling that
among this at 1000 to 2000 women who
seek asylum her and currently locked up
every year only about a quarter of them
actually leave yells were to be deported
the rest are released back into the
community their detention serves no
purpose a most of these women that we
talk to in the ours word they've already
experienced such extreme human rights
abuses you know they fled often sexual
violence torture human rights abuses of
all kinds in their home countries and
detention here exacerbates that trauma
levels of self-harm are high at yours
would we have to step up I think as a
country and make sure that we're
treating people with dignity and fairly
that's not to say just to pass open
borders anyone come in is to say dignity
you know we're a nation that opposed the
rule of law we hope and therefore people
have to be treated as you say the
judgments have to be made one of the
judgments is one of the issues these are
the judgments aren't made quickly enough
they're not about a lot of time that
people are being held suddenly people
we've worked with women who locked up
for days weeks months even more than a
year and because immigration is
indefinite the women who are in
detention that they don't know how long
their detention is going to go on for
it's not like being locked up if you've
committed an offense when you have a
specific tariff that you can count down
from they just don't know and that in
itself is very traumatic and very
harmful and detention is also expensive
you know it's more expensive to lock
people up than it is to process claims
in the in the community just wanna hear
some of your personal experience inside
we've we've heard it there from the town
visits and visited yards with many times
and met you there
just tell me about conditions there and
for instance access to education for you
well when I was in there I found myself
dipping cut potatoes into color and then
stamping the blank paper when I was 13
years old
so education wise there is actually
nothing as the kids you know I was
thinking what did I do wrong because
surely to go from eight metal doors you
have to do something wrong
and the education it doesn't exist
health care there is a room which is
called a health center but nothing
happens their health is very bad in
y'all's word and these are the most
important things I mean if they don't
exist then why should the whole place
exist and it's not sure there are some
people listen to this and say well look
you know you know you're asking to to
come uninvited to come and live in the
United Kingdom we have to make it fairly
difficult we have to bear in mind that a
lot of people who pass through this
detention they do actually come to get
leave to remain in this country you know
they they're playing by the rules
they're claiming asylum and they often
end up getting refugee status so there's
no reason to treat them cruelly in
humanely on the way particularly it's
more expensive and inefficient to do so
what's quite heartening is although we
haven't yet seen any change at y'all's
would since the campaign began we are
seeing more political response now I
mean you mentioned all together and
there's no need to to hold anyone
whatsoever yeah I think there's no need
for detention in the asylum process the
assign process can work perfectly well
with people's claims being heard in the
community and we have had responses now
from MPs of all right across the party
is a Conservative MP on International
Women's Day stood up and said in the
House of Commons you know this should be
ended we've had responses from the
Minister saying he wants to reduce the
detention of vulnerable people so we
hope that step-by-step we can get to a
more humane system in this country and
one that I think you know we as British
people can be a bit more proud of ok
melting we have to get
well not the end of your story that's
away you where you are now what's
happened to you now where are you living
what's the education like and what's
happened to your mother well she's doing
very well you you're together yes yeah
of course was we always together we were
locked up together as well I study now
I was working recently I try and see it
as a very not a positive experience of
course but I'm taking the good out of it
that now I find you my freedom more for
example my education more my health more
so I'm doing well and your attitude to
to see the United Kingdom after this
experience you want to I mean still very
young you want to stay in the United
Kingdom joint to make a contribution to
to this society what you'll view after
this experience I'm already making the
contributions to the society of course I
want to stay because for us it's like we
were treated in a worse way in our
countries no matter you know where we
come from as refugees so here is like
heaven to us as corny as that sounds
well very good to hear we must end it
there thank you very much thank you so
much you did melton have some uh Natasha
water thank you once again